I love this story this is a meme ABC
news says Trump's unprecedented campaign
speech campaign pitch Trump's
unprecedented campaign pitch elect me to
get revenge on the government Mega baby
yeah right I love it because they write
this unironically and Libertarians
post-liberals Trump supporters are
screen grabbing it and posting the Chad
meme with just yes yes yes that's the
most compelling thing I've ever heard a
politician say in my life yes get
revenge on the government sign me up
look at this Donald Trump has told
supporters not to just see him as a
candidate but as quote your retribution
yes Milo said this was on the show said
this he said in his comeback bed for the
White House the former president twice
impeached but twice acquitted now twice
indicted haha has vowed that if
re-elected he will wield his power to
personally remake parts of the federal
government to a degree that historian
mark up thegrove said was unprecedented
Trump has promised to hamstring
perceived enemies including the doj
which is currently investigating him and
Target Republican Boogeyman like
President Republican bogeyman like
President Joe Biden sounds like they're
saying Joe Biden's a republican he's
swore in June to appoint a special
prosecutor to go after the bidens
okay good and that he would totally
obliterate the Deep state I'm not
hearing any insult or negativity you
know referring to a conspiratorial view
of how the government operates
this is the final battle either they win
or or we win he said the Libertarians
just got out libertarian by The Bump
Stop guy what are you doing
well come on look look yeah I mean uh I
think it's an excellent I think it's an
excellent speech but what's his policy
actually going to be how is he really
going to do it just so we know chainsaw
but is he going to take out the IRS is
he going to take out doe what are you
actually going to do does Santa said he
was going to do that didn't he something
that he talked about Department of
Education yeah oh education education
which is I mean I love it yeah
if if all Donald Trump at this point has
is they have slighted me and I will fire
them I'll be like okay take my vote I
mean fire them all I like can
Libertarians disagree I mean you know
fireman and I don't think that he would
be entirely successful but it would be a
lot of fun to watch him try yeah I think
he'd be successful at this point I mean
I I I I just want to stress
I don't think he did a perfect job at
his first term I didn't vote for him in
2016. I think he did some these
moderately good things with in terms of
foreign policy I really liked and uh
some culture War issues he was very late
in the game too so he's not he wasn't my
first choice a your guy said DeSantis
because DeSantis has been on top of the
the game when it comes to uh culture War
issues but Donald Trump comes out and
he's like don't know don't care I want
revenge I'm gonna fire everybody and I'm
like I see fire in his eyes
that's all I can ask for well it's not
necessarily about the American people
it's his revenge but we all may benefit
from him that's right and I mean like
considering how selfish and narcissistic
the guy is I want him to make it
personal because that's way more of a
motivator than me right like I'm not
Donald Trump doesn't give a crap about
me if I'm standing on the sidewalk and
there's like
you know a guy behind me and I see Trump
barreling full speed power walking all
angry I'm getting out of the way right
I'm gonna be like Oh I'm not gonna don't
let me stand in your way sir and that
may mean you are not getting what you
want but the guy behind you turns out to
be a Mugger that was after you and so
I'm like I'll take it if you're in a war
zone and you're at your enemy gets hit
with Friendly Fire thumbs up like that's
cool like they're they if they're gonna
smoke each other take each other out
fine if Donald Trump wants to go in
there and actually make Cuts go get him
isn't it funny how terrified the
corporate press is though
why are journalists so scared that
someone would fire bureaucrats access
because they're friendly with it with
the bureaucrats now and because they get
they have their personal email addresses
and their personal home phone numbers
and sometimes they get Scoops so it's
all about access one of the hardest
things I think would be if he's talking
about getting rid of the deep State it's
it's the unelected officials right you
can fire you can fire all the heads of
departments you want but all of those
heads of departments have trained people
under them who think like they do who
they've groomed for those positions
farther up so it's not just getting rid
of whoever you're talking about whether
you're talking about CIA all of these
departments there's going to be somebody
that's going to come in there because
it's not like this is one generation of
a problem this is multi-generational and
it will take more than one president if
you're going to actually turn things
around if this is my opinion and I don't
know for sure what the legality is of
the of the government of the federal uh
the president actually getting rid of
cabinets well that's what I'm saying
like what does that mean mean getting
rid of abolishing like we're not so when
I say get rid of I mean abolish at the
cabinet level so the whole department
from the the seat on the cabinet all the
way down to the you know ground
enforcers of whatever Department we're
talking about whether it be HUD whether
it be the department of energy which I
don't know that we can do that because
of the nuclear stuff but still uh the
department of the Interior dot uh IRS uh
well that's part of the treasury so that
would be a little different but like you
know there's plenty of stuff that he
could Pro that he could get get rid of
as the executive and just be like get
out here in the in the Justice
Department alone he could do stuff with
the F get rid of the stuff of the FBI by
executive order he can get rid of stuff
with the ATF by executive order because
if if I understand correctly I could be
wrong but I that's the way that I
believe because he is the executive of
the or he is the executive he can get
rid of stuff in the Department of
Justice so like that would be a great
place to start FBI and and ATF and stuff
but but the more that he's looking to
cut whoever's looking to cut the most
that's who I'm behind the second most
Cuts is the second person I'm behind
like that it's that simple like I don't
give a crap about any of their
personalities who's going to shrink the
federal government the most because
right now it's the biggest government in
human history so don't tell me we can't
cut Trump should go to libertarian
rallies and be like I'm gonna fire
everybody he shouldn't he should have
gone to pork fest and they're gonna
seriously yeah and they're gonna and
they're gonna be like I really don't
want to vote for bump stock Donnie but
yeah if he really is gonna fire these
people and like you can see the fire in
his eyes and the want for Revenge I mean
you might actually get it yeah that's
that's that's like the difficult
libertarian position I guess you know
even Dave Smith was like there's some
foreign policy stuff he did that was
good and it's like man but also like the
didn't they also question why didn't you
pardon Assange why didn't you yeah that
would have been like had he done that I
would have really liked to have seen
that it felt like a lot of that stuff
the pardons at the end a lot of that
stuff felt very performative uh and
there was more important real change
that he could have made through that
stuff that would have been even on the
way out would have been good for his
re-election campaign Snowden and Assange
has he done that he would have won the
hearts of a lot of Libertarians just
because of that move we did have Don Jr
on and he did say it's time we do pardon
Assange and Snowden and uh I'm not even
as bullish on Snowden to be honest you
know Snowden is is like a middle of the
road thing for me uh Assange is no
brainer Assange shouldn't be charged at
all he's an international journalist who
is wrongly charged with with deep BS
they falsely accuse him of abusing women
not true now they're accusing of
Espionage literally a journalist what
does he do he gets information he
publishes information Snowden was a
leaker Snowden took information gave it
to journalists without knowing what it
was there's an argument to be made that
it was so good what he did exposing
things like xq score and what you know
NSA spying that it's high time we say
look you know no more Exile come on home
man like we we are happy we got this
information and but the thing about
Snowden it's like you know the big issue
is he did not know what he was giving
out he knew some of it but he just took
a bulk thing I'm not all about
encouraging that I like whistleblowers I
think people should expose darkness and
Corruption
but we have Security in this country for
a reason like I like this country I like
the fact that we we defend ourselves you
know you can't just leak everything but
uh that being said even Don Jr said I
think it's it's high time we do pardon
him that doesn't mean uh uh uh Trump
senior would do it but it does show that
there is at least a sphere of influence
in the Trump world that is starting to
be like
let's roll with it I do think the reason
Trump wanted Assange brought to the U.S
was because Assange knows things
pertaining to the clintons The
Establishment neolibs neocons and Trump
wanted that information and Assange
would not give it up because Assange has
integrity and he is a journalist and he
protects his sources
so I think that was a strong component
for Trump he knew he's like this guy's
got information we need and won't give
it up
I also think that the the Intel agencies
are a big part of why we need to to pair
back right it's like you just you can't
you cannot do a lot of this unless we
figure out a way to limit the influence
of these Intel agencies who are
essentially responsible to no one
accountable to no one you're right but
the information that the that we're
worried about the Intel agencies
collecting is the information that we're
voluntarily giving to all the social
media companies and Google and stuff so
I get it you're right and I would I I
don't know what the way or the best way
to prevent the government from just
subpoenaing it because the these
companies are just throwing the
information at the feds as soon as the
feds ask they're just like yeah yeah
because again access because of favor
with the most powerful government ever
so I don't know what the right way to
fix it is but they've already got the
information you know your social media
companies and stuff like that they all
have the information out there so it for
the feds it's just a matter of sending
the subpoena we've given all of our
stuff up but it also seems like the
focus isn't is increasingly more
domestic right yeah we are not focusing
overseas the way we used to we're
focusing a lot more on domestic
terrorism with Patriot front and other
such Federal organizations uh
like it just it just feels like that's
where a lot of those cuts would need to
come but it's going to be very hard to
do that because they're so burrowed into
our government well the whole patreon
act itself you know it's called The
Patriot Act because it sounds awesome
but all it is is oh that too as I said
Patriot front Patriot front uh another
group you know domestic terrorists and
that's a big part of our Focus here in
this country now is they're using that
as a weapon against regular Americans
who are not idiots like Patriot runs
that's the federal theater kid exactly
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time